PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's try to solve this.
So my classical approximation is
about solving these equations.
So let's see what we get.
Well, the first equation
is kind of simple.
I think everybody has the
temptation there to just take
the square root, and
that's what we should do,
s0 prime is equal to
plus minus p of x.
And therefore s0 of x is equal
to plus/minus the integral up
to x of p of x prime dx prime.
You see p of x is
pretty much known.
If you know the energy
of your particle,
then it's completely known,
and it depends on e minus v.
So this is a solution
in terms of p of x.
We should think of solving
the differential equation
in terms of p of x.
Now, as a first order
differential equation,
there's a constant
of integration.
And we'll pick it up to
be a number here, x0.
So we start integrating
from some place.
If you integrate
from another place,
you're shifting the
constant of integration.
The main thing is
that the x derivative
here acts as the upper
limit and gives you
the p of x of that equation.
So this is our solution.
Even the plus minus
should not disturb us.
If you have the p
squared, you don't
know if the particle is moving
to the left or to the right.
So that ambiguity is
perfectly reasonable.
Particle can be moving to
the left or to the right.
Now, we look at the
second equation.
So s1 prime is
equal to i over 2.
s0 double prime, if you
have s0 double prime,
you have here s0 prime, so
you take another derivative.
So that's a plus minus p prime
of x divided by s0 prime,
which is plus minus p of x.
That's kind of nice.
The sine is going to cancel.
So we have here i over 2 p
prime of x over p of x or i
over 2 logarithm
of p of x prime.
The derivative of the logarithm
is 1 over the function,
and then by chain rule,
you get the p prime there.
So if s1, the prime
derivative is the derivative
of this thing, so
s1 is going to be
i over 2 log of p of
x plus a constant.
So let's reconstruct
our solution.
That's not hard.
We wrote the answers up there.
So the wave function is e
to the i over h bar times s,
and s is what we had there.
So our wave function is
e to the i over h bar s,
and s was s0 plus
i plus h bar is 1.
There's more.
Is it right?
But we're going to ignore it.
We didn't go that far.
In fact, nobody goes higher
in the WKB approximation.
So what do we have here?
I'll write it.
This term is kind
of interesting.
We have e to the i h bar
of x times e to the i s1.
And s1 was i over 2 log
of p of x plus a constant.
So look at this items
i is minus 1, 2.
So you have 1/2.
This becomes e to the minus
1/2 logarithm of b of x.
And 1/2 the logarithm
of b of x is
e to the minus log of square
root of b of x, and when you go
like that e to minus that
is 1 over the function.
So p of x like that, and then
we have e to the i over h
bar integral from x0 to
x p of x prime dx prime.
This is the classic WKB
approximation, classic result.
So as promised, this is of the
form of a scale factor here,
a rho, the square root
of rho times a phase.
So we did begin with what
looked like a pure phase,
but then we said s of
x is complicit in fact.
s0 was real, but
s1 was imaginary.
With s1 imaginary, the rho of
s1 was to provide the magnitude.
And this is an intuition,
this approximation scheme.
The first thing you have
to get right is the phase.
Once you get the phase
right, the next order,
you get the amplitude
of the wave right.
That comes to second order.
That's a next effect.
So this is our solution.
When I began today,
I reminded you
that we have WKB solutions of
the form square root of rho
e to the is, and we calculated
some things for that.
So because of the
signs, s0, I dropped
the sign, this plus or minus.
Let me write the
general solutions of WKB
slightly more complete.
Let's be more complete.
It's important to see
the whole freedom here.
So if we have e greater
than v, remember
when e is greater than v, the
p of x is a real quantity.
And we wrote, and
we said that p of x
we would write as h bar k of x.
You know, I think I should have
probably, for convenience here,
let's put the constant.
We're not attempting to
normalize these wave functions.
We could not attempt
to do it, because we
don't know what p of x is.
And this function may
have limited validity
as we've spoken.
But I had the constants here.
This constant could have
a real or imaginary part.
It would affect this a.
So let's put it there.
OK.
So if p of x is hk of x, we can
have the following solutions,
psi of x and t equal a, another
constant, square root of p--
let's go simpler--
square root of k.
It's a different a.
And here, e to the i, since
p is h bar, it cancels here.
So we have a simpler
integral as well,
x0 to x, k of x prime, dx prime.
So that's that term.
I just use the
opportunity to replace p
for k, which
simplifies your life,
simplifies all these constants.
So the other solution
is the wave moving
in a different direction.
So k of x, e to the
minus i x0 to x,
k of x prime v of x prime.
So that is your solution when
you have e greater than v.
If we have e less than v,
we still have a solution,
and we said that p
of x, in that case,
would be equal to
i h bar kappa of x.
We use that notation.
If e is less than v, this
is a negative number.
So p of x is i times
some positive number
and square root of
a positive number.
And we called it
kappa last time.
So this is the
letter we usually use
for spatial
dependence in regions
where the wave function
decays exponentially,
which is what it's
going to happen here.
So what is the psi of x and
t is equal to a constant c
over square root of
kappa of x e to the--
the i will disappear,
and there will
be two solutions, one
with plus, one with minus.
That's the reason I don't have
to be very careful in saying
whether this is i or minus i.
There's, anyway, two solutions.
At this stage, we
don't need to worry.
So this is from x0 to x,
kappa of x prime, dx prime,
plus d over square root of
kappa of x, e to the minus x0
to x, kappa of x
prime, dx prime.
So this is the complete
solution of WKB.
If you are in the classically
allowed region top
or in the classically
forbidden region,
it's important to realize that
this function, the second term
is the decaying exponential.
As x increases, the integral
accumulates more and more
value, and the wave function
gets more and more suppressed.
This is a growing
kind of exponential.
In the previous
iteration in your life,
kappa was a constant, if
you had constant potentials.
And this would be e to
the kappa x basically.
But here, you must
think of kappa
being some positive
number, positive function,
as you integrate and x grows,
your cube-- the integral
becomes bigger.
And this is a
growing exponential.
So the sign tells you that,
especially because we've
ordered the limits properly.
So we have a decaying
and growing exponential.
At this moment,
we're pretty much
done with what WKB does for you.
Although, we have a few
things still to say.
So this will be in
terms of comments
about the general validity
of such approximation,
but first even some comments
about the current and charge
density.
So let's consider
this equation I.
Let's just make the comments,
comments for equation I on one.
What is the charge density
or the probability density
in this case, rho
would be psi squared,
and in case one, is equal
to a squared over k of x?
You could, if you wish, this
is a perfectly nice formula,
multiply it by h
bar up and down.
And that's the momentum.
So it's h bar a
squared over p of x.
And you could say
this is h bar over m
a squared over v of x,
a local velocity, p of x
is m over a local velocity.
And this is an intuition
you've had for a long time.
The probability density or
the amplitude of the wave
is going to become
bigger in the regions
where the particle
has smaller velocity.
That's the regions of
the potential where
the particle spends
more time, and it's
an intuition that almost
immediately comes here.
This k is essentially
the momentum.
So that's essentially the
square root of the velocity.
And this coefficient,
therefore, becomes bigger,
as the velocity is smaller.
That's part of the intuition
you've had for a long time,
regarding these quantities.
The other piece
is the computation
of the current from this
equation I. Remember,
the current is h bar over
m times the imaginary part
of psi star gradient psi.
So it's a long computation.
But we did it for the
case we had before.
We said that the current
is rho times gradient of s
over m for the case when
the wave function is
written in rho e to the s form.
So in here, rho is
already determined
is a squared over k of x.
We have the 1 over m,
and the gradient of s--
s is this quantity, e
to the i h bar times s.
So the gradient of s is just
p of x, so h bar k of x.
Now, they cancel.
And it's very fast.
They cancel.
Would have been a major
disaster if they didn't.
This is a number.
It's a squared over m.
The reason it cancels is
that it would have failed
the conservation law otherwise.
The rho dt plus the
divergence of j should be 0.
In our case, rho has
no time dependence.
The wave function that
we are considering,
our time independent
Schrodinger equations,
we're considering
energy eigenstates.
And the current
must be a constant.
In an energy eigenstate, the
current cannot be a spatially
varying constant, because then
the current would accumulate
in some place, and that's
inconsistent with stationary
states.
And in fact, this is 0, and
the versions of j in this case
would be dj dx, and if it would
have had some x dependence,
it would have destroyed
this equation.
So dj dx is also 0, and
that's all consistent.